[Music]  Milo Ventimiglia gets emotional at  PaleyFest are you willing to lift him to  greater heights even if it hurts  [Music]  during the vistas US panel at PaleyFest  on Saturday the 39 year old actor teared  up when explaining who he draws  inspiration from in real life while  playing his character Jack Milo's  parents Peter and Carol were in the  audience as was et's Desiree Murphy who  said there wasn't a dry eye in the house  he spoke with Milo on the red carpet at  the event where he opened up about his  beloved character now do you personally  know how Jack died yeah I know how I  know and I know all of it yeah how can  anybody take Williams death and then  Jack's death come on people I think  people want to see death which sucks  let's see life how about we see life I  agree  [Music]  you